[Music]
as I mentioned Nicola had had had given
a version of this talk I think in 20
2013 I think it was for for our friend
Tim Wang's macro Cities conference here
and a number of long no member your
staff saw it and got really excited
about it and we while it took a little
while to get her to speak here she has
been hard at work going deep on this
subject and we now have the benefit
actually I think of the first time she's
spoken about this for a while because
she's been so working so hard in
researching the book the book is coming
out next year we're getting a little
sneak peek at it tonight Nicola twilly
is a writer known for her long-running
blog edible geography she's also
co-founder and co-host of the gastropod
podcast and her writing appears in
publications like the Atlantic New York
Times Magazine and the New Yorker
regularly and tonight we have her here
to tell us about the artificial
cryosphere a big round of applause for
Nicky Nicky boy
all right thank you thank you guys for
coming out tonight
I have a simple goal I have a few goals
I mean I'd like to not completely
embarrass myself trip over forget to
breathe choke all sorts of goals like
that but my main goal for you all is to
reintroduce you to your refrigerator you
have one I'm a bet because 100 percent
of Americans do basically a government
data's so close to make no difference in
fact if if the statistics are right a
quarter of you in this room have two or
more so you you're familiar with the
item about which I speak but you may not
have given it much thought maybe you
occasionally think I have to clean it if
you work at home like me you might open
it in search of inspiration on a regular
basis if you work in an office it might
be the site of some low-level passive
aggressive behaviors if you're unlucky
it might have broken down maybe the day
before Thanksgiving that's a good one
but you what you won't have appreciated
is that your refrigerator is actually a
portal a into a magical space that I
call the artificial cryosphere where the
normal laws of time and space are
suspended and your food lives in an
eternal winter so that is but this is
this is the place we'd built for our
food to live in and it's it's where I'm
taking you tonight the fridge your
fridge at home is literally the tip of
an iceberg so the the United States is
the most refrigerated country in the
world we have more than a hundred
million cubic meters of thermal
control that means nothing to me but
once I did the math and that is actually
not so much smaller than the Arctic so
basically we built a third pole for our
food to live in which is incredible and
then you know all these separate
refrigerated spaces are connected by a
cold chain so you end up with this sort
of seamless need a monument of
engineered winter and the thing that
happened to me is that I realized I had
been writing about food for a decade at
this point when I first sort of turned
my attention to the cold chain and and I
realized I had visited farms and I had
visited factories and obviously I'd talk
to chefs and I had I'd even been to the
grocery store on occasion but I had
never been inside a refrigerated
warehouse and I'm gonna guess most of
you haven't either and here we are in
the bay area which you know home of
farm-to-table but that to word it goes
via the refrigerated warehouse like in
between farm and table is a giant cold
space that nobody thinks about so I
decided to explore it and first of all I
partnered with the Center for land use
interpretation which those of you
haven't heard of it you are in for a
treat when you google it later but we
mapped the American cryosphere and and
then I still wasn't done so then I wrote
a piece for the New York Times magazine
that took me to China to explore their
artificial cryosphere
and then I still wasn't done so then I
decided to sell a book on this topic and
and research that and write that and
that is still not done but that's a
whole other story but yeah so I have
gone deep into this artificial quite a
cryosphere and my goal tonight is say
let's go on a quick spin through this
space past present future
and I have so I hope you wrapped up
warmly we are stepping inside and I want
to start this thing right with a banquet
this in its time was the most talked
about meal in the United States the
organizers had originally booked quite a
small room they had to upgrade to the
largest banqueting-hall in Chicago the
guest list kept expanding a member of
Congress decided they wanted to come
then other members of Congress decided
they wanted to come people were were
flooding this and and so what is so
special about this meal you ask yourself
well this was the world's first cold
storage banquet everything on the menu
had been stored under refrigeration so
except I should point out for the olives
in the dry martini not refrigerated so
this is tecna's took place on Monday
October 23rd 1911 and there's there's
you know thousand people in the room
white linen you know full table service
the crystal out the the result was two
hours of what industry Journal the egg
reporter called unalloyed pleasure and
what is amazing about it is that
everything on the menu had spent at
least six months and up to a year in
cold storage and and what I love about
this menu too is and again you know here
in the Bay Area we are used to seeing
who grew our you know this is Mary's
chicken or this is like this particular
heirloom variety of tomato do we ever
see what cold storage it was in we do
not here we have booths cold storage
proud you know the last address of that
salmon and and so the that was that was
sort of
and and the sort of introduction to the
mail explained well your turkey that's
11 months old your eggs 7 months the the
president of the natural national
poultry butter and egg Association who
was kind of giving this introduction set
your cape on received its summons to the
great unknown last Valentine Day the the
pie even the pike old stored flour
butter turned in June apples and this is
October so they could they could have
had fresh but no they'd been in storage
alongside the salmon at booths for a
year the head chef of the hotel where
this was being served said man called
Lucia there has never been a better meal
served at this hotel
the San Antonio reporter expressed
whatever the journalist from there said
nothing was quite fresh the the poultry
men the president the poultry Mon
Association said this is edible proof
that cold stored foods are not only good
they're better than the ones that you
would eat fresh and the congressman who
was called upon to sort of speak agreed
and said yes I really believe that there
is more flavor to cold storage poultry
than the kind that is advertised as
freshly killed and he said I'm going
back to Washington I'm telling the folks
cold storage is where it's at so this
this this kind of lunch became a
national trend so la held the next one
then there was one in Detroit there was
one in Philly two years later there was
another one in Chicago
with literally thousands of people and a
special three page souvenir brochure
with not only where the food had been
stored but also the temperature and
relative humidity for her to be in
stored so became a trend and and this is
barely more than a century ago so
more than 3/4 of everything in America
has either been stored or processed or
shipped under refrigeration so you would
actually have a harder time eating a
meal that wasn't cold stored than one
that was so it's kind of amazing to me
that that you know how to understand why
this meal caused a national flutter less
than more than only just more than a
hundred years ago and so to understand
that you really have to under well you
have to be able to imagine life pre
refrigeration and so life without
artificial refrigeration is obviously
most of humanity's existence and the the
challenge is that the things that make
us like food which is that it's full of
nutrients and water are also the things
that make it really attractive to
bacteria and fungi and when they eat our
dinner first we call that rot and and we
find it upsetting and and so watching
watching food rot is is horrifying
in part because for most of history it
was existentially threatening but it's
also kind of mesmerizing and I will say
again for your amusement later this
evening there is a lot there's there are
entire YouTube channels of food rotting
like different I took this screenshot
the next suggested autoplay video was
the cult favorite rotting sausage which
I did not include a screenshot for and
you can thank me for that later but but
it is it is strangely fascinating
actually one of my favorite moments of
rotting research was that in 2011 the
entirety of the British Isles basically
tuned in to what was what was called the
rot box on the BBC and the be this this
makes it sound like some country that
got TV about 10 years ago
obviously the BBC is a fine institution
but what they did was put a bunch of
food on a soundstage at Edinburgh Zoo
and then essentially the entire British
public spent two months in the summer of
2011 watching the food rot in real time
and then they were like televised you
know check-ins on what had happened you
know as the kind of vegetables collapsed
on themselves and the chicken kind of
bloated and good and then started
leaking and the maggots hatched and etc
so rot for most of human history has
been a mystery as well as a feared enemy
of many of you will know that you know
it was so sort of it was held up as the
sort of the central kind of plank in the
theory of spontaneous generation because
otherwise how could life emerge from
nothing well look at the maggots on a
piece of meat it took Louis Pasteur to
disprove that but um but figuring out
how to stop the rot it has been
essentially sort of one of the primary
focuses of human ingenuity for most of
history and our earliest experiments in
biological warfare warfare and the
source of some of our most delicious
foods so you have things like drying you
have salting you have pickling you have
all of these kind of things that give us
the delicious salty smoky sour fermented
funky things that are what is good about
eating for the most part and those that
those flavors that's the signature of
pre refrigeration cuisine I like to say
it's it's like this is this is the best
thing going in a world full of
monotonous grain you know these kind of
flavor bombs not only had you saved the
food you'd Bank the harvest against the
lean season it made it portable in a lot
of cases
and it tasted amazing this is like
humanity's greatest triumph there's a
but but but underlying it and I feel
like I will never look at cheese the
same way again
is this the once you realize it's like
this sense of incredible urgency there's
an Italian historian who has a quote
that I love that that that says
preserving is anxiety in its purest form
that's that's cheese so these things are
great but what they are not is they're
not the same as fresh right no one is
gonna mistake
smoked salmon for fresh fish
no one is going to mistake a pickled
cabbage for a fresh one or cheese for
milk or anything like that you know the
things you have to do to you know the
scorched earth policy of getting rid of
the microbes that also changes the
flavor and the texture and the
appearance of the food so refrigeration
changes all that there's the new the the
the the systematic widespread use of
cold preserved food is it's basically an
entirely new chapter in human nutrition
you overcome seasonality you come
overcome geography and you stop the rot
so obviously well first of all a thing
that I learned embarrassingly late in my
refrigeration research cold is actually
just the absence of heat all of you know
that I know but I didn't it's a while
Humanity is known how to add heat to
food for a really long time removing
heat turns out to be very challenging
and so humans had noticed that cold had
the power to stop time and actually some
of the first ice houses are 4,000 years
ago
along the banks of the Euphrates ancient
Romans and Greeks would purchase ice
carried down from the mountains to chill
their wines and things like that in the
1600s this is another kind of rabbit
hole but I sort of had a trend in
England to chill custards and jellies
and things like that and so a lot of
fancy houses had had ice houses
elsewhere on their property and there's
a theory that I love that the pervasive
myths myths about hobbits and little
people dwelling underground in England
is because of all the ice houses because
I mean they usually kind of set away
from dwellings they're little doors and
a little like round circles and and yeah
so hobbits or ice houses you you decide
but but obviously this was not these are
not reliable widespread kind of systems
of cooling and and it actually it took a
a 23 year old Bostonian called Frederic
Tudor to turn natural cold into a global
industry in 1805 he got started and he
in in the next 50 years he developed the
tools which you can kind of see an
operation up there
he developed a global network of ice
houses you can again sort of see the
scope of the trade he developed the most
ingenious business model so the the ice
trade sort of worked on the basis that
ships often needed a ballast on their
way out and we're good then gonna bring
stuff home to American consumers so you
could ship out the ice bring stuff home
to America
it was offseason for the farmers who
owned the pond so they were happy to
harvest in the winter they had nothing
nothing else to do and there was an
amazing tax loophole right
the IRS couldn't classify ice harvesting
as either mining or farming so they just
ignored it
so he absolutely coined it in by 1900
the ice industry employed 90,000 people
and was worth 220 million in today's
money it was North America because it
had so much freshwater and so much cold
it was considered sort of like the saudi
of you know this resource you know like
like saudi oil is today our ice was then
and then by 1930 this has completely
disappeared so this I actually went to a
nice harvest up in Maine it's one of the
few ones that still happens it was very
popular the particular year I went
because frozen had just come out and a
lot of people bringing their kids and
then they sell the ice blocks on an
honor system to fishermen who prefer coz
melts more slowly than artificial ices
fewer air bubbles in it and then they
blow whatever is left in July on a giant
ice cream social that I happened to go
back for so it's kind of fun but what is
so the the the natural ice industry is
fascinating but will how it relates to
the artificial cryosphere
is that what became what had started as
a sort of a decadent thing this was eat
this ice was used for chilling cocktails
or you know a sort of ice cream and
things like that it ended up kind of
proving that there was a business model
for cold there was a demand there was a
global demand and a commercial value for
preserving the food and that really
inspired a whole generation of inventors
to to master artificial cold because
they saw you could make money from
natural cold so let's get on this so
they do eventually and any of you who
are familiar with the sort of stories of
how a new technology gets started will
be familiar with how difficult this is
there's getting it to work there's
scaling it up
there's
making it economic you know how could
for for most of the 1800s it could not
compete at all with all of the 1800s it
couldn't compete with natural ice it's
too expensive so what happens how does
the how does artificial cold take over
well during the Civil War the South was
cut off from northern ice so there so
inventors took a took a chance there to
build some prototype ice factories but
really what happened was lager primarily
there were a lot of German immigrants
Americans went from drinking not very
much beer to much much more beer and you
cannot make blog or bear without
consistent cold temperatures so that led
to a huge investment in refrigeration
technology then the the next big driver
is pollution right we have all these
nice fresh waterways the Hudson used to
give New York all of its ice and then as
the city's scale up and the rivers are
used as open sewers the ice that comes
out of them is new so fresh and pleasant
and natural ice starts to look more
attractive widespread electrification is
obviously a driver obviously helps the
discovery of vitamins plays a huge or
what you will all call vitamins plays a
huge role so previously things like so
this happened in the early years that
the 1900s previously things like lettuce
it been seen as like that's nice and
decorative but what is the point which
some people say still share that but
once you know vitamins have been
discovered everyone was like oh we
actually need fresh fruit and vegetables
there's a purpose to these things
they're not just kind of decoration so
and and vitae mania sort of swept the
nation so that led a huge amount and
then the kind of final push over the
edge was prohibition
so all these beer makers who have
invested absolutely shed loads in their
ice making equipment
to fulfill America's desire for lager
beer are certainly not able to make and
sell their lager beer so they're like
what shall we do so they start using
their refrigerated equipment for food
and then Americans get used to it so
either one I love is a bush the beer
company of Fame they got in the frozen
eggnog business during Prohibition and
also developed a very popular ice cream
bar called smack so these are the forces
that made artificial refrigeration that
have actually kinda the natural ice
industry kind of melted away as if it
had never existed and an America becomes
used to to cold but there's still this
user resistance and that brings us to
the era of these cold storage banquets
people just didn't they they saw cold
store foods as zombie foods I mean what
kind of unnatural technology could make
a chicken a two-year-old chicken look
the same as a just harvested it just I
mean that's just not right right that's
not I mean if you were you know if you
actually think about it that's freaky
and they and and if you people you know
they had a way of thinking about food
there was a known physics of freshness
that had to do with seasons and time and
geography and all of a sudden those
rules were broken and they did not
understand the new reality so you get a
situation where people you know have to
take out ads cold storage eggs are good
there are big national debates with you
know doctors on either side cold storage
foods bad they will you know disrupt the
delicate nervous system etc no cold
storage foods are good etc people built
their cold storage warehouses to look
like banks or fortresses like safe
places to put your food and save it
whereas nowadays they're like boxes on
the edge of town that
that no one is supposed to look at so
there was this and and it was so
successful that now
I mean people Oh though my favorite
thing is it became a sort of named
medical disorder frig aura fo B this may
it's sort of a rabbit hole I went into
the book but they were so successful
that now people don't think things are
fresh if they don't have to go in the
fridge there's there's a mistrust of
things that don't come from the fridge
because how could they be fresh and we
rely on a sell-by date which is you know
sort of a refrigeration driven
innovation to tell us whether
something's fresh rather than our own
understanding of kind of how freshness
works and when say silk soymilk was
introduced
they paid extra to be shelved in a
refrigerator in the refrigerated section
of the supermarket rather than on the on
the regular shelves even though it's a
perfectly shelf stable product because
people would not think it was fresh if
it did not have to be refrigerated so
it's sort of gone 180 in that quick of a
time so the book goes sort of
step-by-step through the evolution and
impacts of various bits of refrigeration
technology so the invention of the
charmingly named reefer which is a
refrigerated container and this this
lady who spent her 20s living in a
shipping container to try to figure out
how to make this this technology work
and she still works in refrigeration and
it goes through kind of what happens to
different foods so how the invention of
refrigerated they're called tank farms
for orange juice turns this very
perishable thing into something that is
a breakfast drink for you know twenty
percent of Americans and and become a
you know orange juice goes from
something that's freshly squeezed at
home very variable very perishable into
something that can be a brand it tastes
the same
Tropicana can taste
same every time and that's different to
Minute Maid because you're storing it in
a giant tank and you can regularize the
flavor it also turns it into a financial
instrument you might be wondering why I
would put a fixture trading places up
there but for those of you who don't
remember the climax of this fabulous
movie involves trading orange juice
futures so something is pair of
perishable as orange juice can become a
financial instrument all of a sudden and
similarly you know while refrigeration
is changing where things are grown how
how we buy it how it gets to us what it
tastes like it's also reformatting the
landscape this is a feedlot and it's an
aerial photographer photographed by a
photographer called Mishka Henner and um
and that doesn't that landscape makes no
sense without refrigeration obviously
you couldn't call that a landscape of
corn Michael Pollan would call that a
landscape of corn but it's also a
landscape of refrigeration it does not
make any sense to have a feedlot without
refrigeration
the other thing that I like is you know
of course because we are what we eat
we have been reformatted by
refrigeration too so there folks hard at
work at figuring out what the
refrigeration microbiome is how our
refrigerated diet changes our microbiome
but there are some Duke University
researchers who figured out that of all
the sort of shifts in public health and
all sorts of things over the twentieth
century of that have changed added
height to emit the average American a
full quarter inch of that is down to
refrigeration so they have an extensive
paper it's a it is an amusing read but
yes a quarter and you can thank
refrigeration for a quarter inch of your
height on average so in the US all these
changes took place mostly in the first
half of the 20th century a little beyond
and so they're basically invisible to us
now which is why we look at our food
system and we think it's normal but
we're actually seeing a lude system that
is completely distorted
refrigeration and what's interesting is
if you go to a place that has only just
refrigerated or is still refrigerating
you can see those shifts take place
which is why I went to China to visit
the the the factory of the frozen
dumpling mogul who brought frozen food
to China this is the frozen dumpling
Factory he was the surgeon and wen dong
shopping said oh you know some people
are going to get rich this surgeon
decided he would like to be one of those
and so he harvested some parts from some
of the hospital machinery and built a
freezer system he was already famous in
the neighborhood for his homemade
dumplings and he just started a a
dumpling factory but what's amazing is
when you go there you can see the same
things play out that played out here so
there was an initially a very intense
distrust and there still is amongst a
certain generation when I talk to folks
about could could refrigerated and
frozen food be good could it really be
okay and and the present dumpling mogul
told me that actually the drip right
there on the dumpling is very important
that signified freshness they tried to
sell the dumplings in a in a package
without the drip and and they weren't
selling and the drips somehow sort of
communicated a freshness to folks you
can I visited people who are we who are
breeding Chinese vegetables to be cold
storage tolerant so their vegetables are
changing in real-time their diets are
changing where things are grown is
changing this is a big Chinese
government project called the south to
north vegetable transfer that is
shifting where things are grown these
are Chinese apples going out to the
world it's changing where where food is
sold so wet markets they're turning into
Walmart's and that changes how often
people shop it changes the layout of
their
houses it changes the layout of cities
so you could see all of those things
kind of changing in real time and what's
crazy about China is so in 2010 the
Chinese government's a made
refrigeration part of their 12th
five-year plan they were like we are
going to refrigerate and being China
they just did it and so it has in the
past 10 years the amount of refrigerated
space in China has grown by more than 20
times it is is just exploded and yet
still Chinese people have less than a
third of the cold storage space of a
average American per capita so it's
still happening and it's happening now
in India and it's happening with Chinese
funding in Africa so the world is
refrigerating at speed and a lot of
people are like whoa this is a good
thing right because diets improve people
have access to fresh vegetables and
dairy and more animal protein that's
exciting
farmers are not stuck selling all their
harvests when it comes in they can
export they can make money they can they
don't and and and then the big thing
that people say is will food waste right
when you don't have a cold chain you
lose a lot of food so in a country like
India where there isn't a robust cold
chain and estimates are that a that at
least 40% is lost before it you know at
the farm stage basically before it ever
gets anywhere close to the consumer in
America where we have an amazing cold
chain
well we waste 40 percent on the consumer
end so the cold chain people
refrigeration boosters like to say it
prevents food waste but I think it's a
little more nuanced than that it kind of
just shifts where it happens and maybe
makes it easier to fix I don't know
maybe not this actually strikes me as
harder to fix in a lot of ways but so
that but that brings me to sort of the
final chapter of my refrigeration book
which is this fabulous irony that
building an artificial cryosphere is
basically
led to the certain end of our natural
one because it's um
so at the moment currently the energy
required for cooling is 1/6 of the
global electricity burden that's all
cooling for buildings that you know
people - so not just food
no one is broken it out by just food but
still that's a lot and then imagine ok
even if all all of the energy used to
refrigerate was renewable which it's not
even then you have the problem of
refrigerants which are a gigantic
problem normally these are the liquids
that actually do the heat exchange
process in a refrigerator the ones that
are very popular particularly in the
developing world are called HFCS they're
called super greenhouse gases because
there are thousands of times more
warming than carbon dioxide and if
current trends and refrigerant usage
continue experts say that these HFCS
will be responsible for half of global
greenhouse emissions by 2050 so that's
not gonna happen because people have
people have agreed to scale back their
use of these HFCS and switch to other
refrigerants that are less damaging but
still you can see this is a giant
problem and the UN has just woken up to
it last September I went to speak at the
first meeting of the sustainable cooling
for all meeting at the UN and the idea
was we are cooling is great we need
cooling but how are we going to provide
it sustainably well can that be done
should it be done this is so these are
the questions with which I end my book
and I think there are a few ways to
think about this problem and what the
future of refrigeration should look like
so one is okay the technology is
problematic let's reinvent the
technology and that's the direction that
most effort is going into and obviously
there are some really smart people
there's
you know there are people there's a
there's a guy in a British guy who was
in a shed with a lawnmower and a can of
antifreeze and has invented a
refrigeration engine that is like zero
emissions and is being trialed by
Sainsbury's at the moment so they're
obviously you know great steps being
made in that direction but I also feel
like just designing better refrigeration
technology misses the point a little
because this is something that
redesigned our entire food system it
redesigned us it redesigned the
landscape it redesigned you know our in
our in the layout of cities the layout
of our homes the taste of our food it
redesigned a lot of things and maybe
this is a good moment to think about
well if we're gonna refrigerate the
whole world is that the system that we
want we do better and and so there are a
couple of things that I just want to
leave you with because it's always good
to be like could we do better and then
turn it over to you do you answer that
question but um one is I think we need
to think thermally right cold is a
resource and we could choose not to
waste it
so waste heat recovery gets a lot of
play these days what about waste cold
recovery that's starting to be looked at
at ports with liquid natural gas when
you re gasify that you you throw off a
lot of cold that is currently just
thrown away but what else is at ports
food is at ports you could be cooling
that food with your spare cold
we don't even think of cold as a spare
thing at the moment it's also this is in
Japan they've started a snow cooling
project in Hokkaido and they cool rice
warehouses using snow they figured you
know what we are absenting money to
collect that like plow the streets store
the snow and then get rid of it in the
spring often dumping it in a river and
polluting the river with all the road
salt and all the crap that the snow has
got in it
and so instead they pile it up in these
in these sort of 10 meter high
snowdrifts and it keeps the rice at four
degrees centigrade and 70% humidity
which the rice really likes and then
they sell it under the snow mountain
brand and it's great they have a hundred
they have 140 of these in this region so
it it's kinda thought that was kind of a
you know why not there are a lot of
places with a lot of snow they're just
spending a lot of money to try and get
rid of it
there's also so that's thinking
thermally there's also kind of I want to
pick up on that idea of I just have that
there cuz I like it I'm gonna say
anything about I just want you to enjoy
it
but there's I want to pick up on that
thing that I said about the the rice
liking seventy percent humidity so a lot
of our food it turns out doesn't
actually like the refrigerator very much
and for example tomatoes if you store
them in a snow cooled room they have
higher lycopene they have higher beta
carotene levels if you store asparagus
in a snow cold room at the last two
weeks longer on average food likes human
fruit and vegetables in particular like
humidity and that is not what you get in
a mechanically refrigerated room and so
actually what I think is interesting
about this is well there's an
opportunity to think about this system
from the point of view of the food and
what would it like we built this system
for it may be it may be maybe we could
rethink it from the point of view of the
food and and so this is a fun student
project that I like because it does take
into account what fruits and vegetables
prefer so this is just one aspect of it
which sort of it's got this sort of the
nightshade family and their their love
for humidity I also think if you're if
you're I want to call it an aubergine
what is it called eggplant
if your eggplant is stored on a shelf on
your wall like that would you forget
about it and let it rot you would put so
design from the point of view of the
food design thermally and then the final
kind of thought is will you know maybe
the arc of food preservation technology
that kind of goes from drying to
pickling and to canning to refrigeration
maybe it's not over and so when I first
sort of thought maybe I'll write about a
book about refrigeration I did the smart
thing which was to look and see if
anyone else had written a book about
refrigeration and obviously there are a
lot of really boring textbooks about
refrigeration but the last popular book
for a popular audience was written in
1953 it's called the refrigerated world
or something and slim slim book and I
went to the library and I read it and
and the guy who wrote it
his final page is well you know what all
things pass and I expect very shortly
refrigeration will be replaced maybe by
freeze drying and it's 60 years later 65
even and this guy was wrong
refrigeration is not being replaced
freeze drying is used only for astronaut
ice cream
so but at the risk of being that wrong
myself I feel like refrigeration could
be replaced and so this is just one
example again of where food preservation
might go this is the company in Santa
Barbara called a peel some of you might
have heard of them they've just rolled
out their first products but what
they've designed is a coating that
extends the life of food by restricting
how much oxygen gets in and how much
water gets out and it's a plant-based
lipid technology the guy developed it
because he worked in solar panels and he
just spent a lot of time watching paint
dry on the solar panels and and while
they gave him time to think but it also
gave him an intense knowledge of how to
design coatings really well and so at
the moment it can give you two or three
times the natural shelf life of the item
if it gets to four times
that's refrigeration four times as the
benchmark for a refrigeration the
founder of this company thinks he can
get there so he thinks you will be able
to achieve the same results the same
shelf life as refrigeration using his
coating at ambient temperature and I
feel like what's interesting about that
is ok so what does the food system based
on the coating at ambient temperature
look like what happens to our logistics
systems what happens to where things are
grown what happens to our definition of
freshness will it become something that
we measure completely differently so yes
I find these thoughts about what the
future of the cryosphere will look like
pretty cool do you imagine and that is
where I'm going to leave you tonight
there is obviously a lot to say there's
QA and thank you
thank you Thank You Nikki it's please
there you go thank you so much and it's
so interesting the I mean I think you
said this in there it is it is it is an
attempt to conquer time in a way that
that with with changing how how long we
have a veil that access to food but then
that allows the conquering of space
because then it can be spread around and
and it seems like it also at the same
time for us as consumers it changes the
way it blurs our sense of time because
we don't know how long something would
last if it's not in the refrigerator we
also we lose touch with a sense of the
seasons and what's fresh win is that
something else you explore in a sense a
sense of that for example I mean your
meat is dead hopefully but your your
fruit and vegetables they are still
breathing there they are respiring and
they don't know just because you picked
them that something bad has happened and
so that's their different from from item
to item as well I would expect yeah and
so that's kind of fascinating to me I
don't I I again I feel like you know and
we were joking about how you're bucked
you're not going to heaven because you
let bok choy rot in your just reveal too
much sorry but I feel like once you know
your bok choy is sort of slowly dying it
gives you it gives me a different
relationship yeah it's well there's
empathy just before all the guilts this
so so that's that's actually a good
segue that
to touch briefly on on the auto drawing
which is that you have been getting what
you call fridge selfies from from people
of taking a look at what's inside their
eyes bikes or not and I did this and and
that's where this came from is I felt I
realized the secret shames of it's like
oh I haven't I bought that I don't know
how many months ago and I haven't
opened it yet and like there's a little
too long in the back etc it's a very
personal thing I think to share a
picture of your fridge and there's
actually so in in my chapter that so guy
will go through the cold chain from
warehouse to fridge to what we eat etc
and so in the fridge chapter there's
actually a guy who is the fridge dating
guru and you can tell this is a really
serious intellectual book but he matches
people based on their fridge selfies and
he claims a really high success rate so
if you are looking for love and you know
tinder is not working for you well there
you go so tell us more about your first
of all what's the title of the book and
when it'll be out next year I have to
finish writing it first so but so if we
get good quick good questions here they
make it into the books that's an extra
incentive for your questions in just a
minute it's called the birth of cool and
and the I think that the hope was that
it would be out next fall we will see if
that will happen and tell us more about
your impressed though bang impress so so
tell us more about your research where
you were you going in the field were you
going all over the world and and tell us
some of the more interesting aspects if
you would have what you've been through
in the last several years working on
this well so I've been into a lot of
refrigerated warehouses and actually
what is quite funny is often my
long-suffering husband Jeff who is in
the front row here will come with me and
because we'll be driving through the
middle of the country and I feel like oh
there's an amazing refrigerator
we have to visit and Jeff gets really
cold really easily so he just he's made
me promise that my next book will be
about hot tubs in the tropics because
this has been a very torturous process
for him but no I'm one fun thing I did
this past spring was I actually worked
in a refrigerated warehouse for a while
which was so in my chapter looking at
refrigerated warehouses and meat and
refrigeration and meat I look at both
meat the meat we eat but also what
happens to humans as they work in
refrigerated spaces this is actually a
very difficult environment to work in
and a lot of people just don't make it
the people people just don't show up the
next day and I can understand why there
are four things that this is the sort of
medical mnemonic for what happens to
people as they get too cold it's called
the umbels
they grumble stumble fumble and mumble
and so those are the sort of diagnostic
symptoms of so there's their neuro neuro
that are happening well cold slows
things down and it's doing that to you
too and there is nothing more sort of
visceral than working a refrigerated
warehouse to understand colds
time-stopping powers because a the day
lasts even longer than when you're
sitting in front of your computer
staring at a bank blank patient and you
slow and you don't even realize you're
slowing you're moving slower I mean when
you first come out on the floor and
you're swapping shifts with the people
before you this pace they are moving at
after eight hours in the in the freezer
room which which has a whole other level
to that zombie chickens like the zombie
humans moving the zombie chickens around
what's what's the biggest upside for the
refrigerated system so are we I in terms
of nutrients in terms of fresh food that
that's getting to people is is that
something you're able to is there sort
of a summary of what's because because
obviously the the climate toll is is a
super negative thing but but what's
what's the what's the biggest benefit
that we're getting from this or you know
is it just largely driven by bigger
profits from from from consolidated
brands wanting to sell their stuff
everywhere well don't don't forget that
quarter inch of height that was know
that I think there's a huge amount in
nutrient in nutritional terms and
actually there is a there bean studies
of this which nutrients have increased
and which have decreased what I think is
interesting is the microbiome work
because obviously as our as our
consumption of cold stored foods has
gone up our consumption of traditionally
preserved foods has actually gone down
and that may have had a negative effect
I know you're looking for upside I'm
sorry on our microbiome but it has
undoubtedly had a benefit in terms of
vitamins and access to animal protein
for sure the animal protein has a lot of
benefits going for it and Rose has the
microphone there so get her attention if
you have a question I also want to say
the other upside is just the sheer
delight of eating I mean think about
cold cold is great as a sensation I mean
ice drinks ice cream it's a whole world
of pleasure so
I mean if words upside I mean the
cocktails here are testament to the
beauty of cold many many of them locally
made by the way just so you know where
we're trying to respond suppose I want
it before we take a first audience
question I want to go back for a second
to the to the refrigeration climate
problem the super greenhouse gasses can
you just for for those of you who don't
know the specifics of it is it about the
production is it about how they're
disposed of and and being released
what's what how how exactly are these
it's the all refrigeration systems leak
a certain amount of refrigerant
they just can't not that can be two
percent in a really well maintained
really modern system but it's more
typically like fifteen percent a year
that you're losing so that's quite a bit
so that's what's happening and then
there's the disposal which again there
are protocols around that you might not
follow if you are looking to cut corners
and and so you know we had we can switch
refrigerants and that has been seen to
happen I mean look at the ozone Blair
and us switching wholesale to HF C's
instead which turn out to be these super
greenhouse grasses but we've done it
once we can we can do it again I think
what's interesting about the refrigerant
problem is that those HFCS are
particularly popular in the developing
world because the systems that run them
are easier to run and cheaper to install
and so it's another one of those
situations where it's like no you have
to have our more expensive and harder to
run system because if we had a hundred
years of refrigeration and now you can't
even have one you know okay I think
we've got a question back here you have
any sense of the impact if you could
prove that guy right and talk to people
into freeze-dried instead of frozen well
I mean I think this this edible coating
is sort of the equivalent of that and I
have not done this but my intention is
to sort of map it out a little and see
what would happen
at least with one they're starting with
avocados so I figured I would just kind
of play it out with avocados and see
what would be saved but I I mean I think
it would be a lot the Japanese snow
cooling people did figure out base the
first that that how much they've saved
so they have published on that I don't
have the numbers with me but they have
published exactly how much greenhouse
gas emissions they've saved and money
which is a lot too
so you can you know if you if you look
for the Japanese snow cooling projects
online you can see those numbers all
right we have another there we go
hi there um how much does the food cold
chain compare to the a spoon right right
human cooling and then also computer
cooling is a big thing and factory
cooling food cooling is the biggest
chunk of that I I don't have those
numbers in front of me right now and I
am notoriously bad with calling numbers
when they're not in front of me so I'm
not gonna give you any but at the moment
food cooling is the biggest chunk of
that I believe that's projected to
change
I mean unsurprisingly the world is
getting warmer human cooling is is yeah
and so so you're doing this and thanks
one was the did you say that last book
was that that looked at refrigeration
that's okay so we're due for an update
this is great every half century we
should check in on those folks audience
yeah and so and so this is a great kind
of view and to bring it all together and
look at that from standpoint in terms of
fixing it obviously there are a lot of
different parts to this system I wonder
are there is there governance are there
regulations that affect pieces of this
that could be a knob that are turned is
that something that we need or are there
other are there things that you've seen
in in in your research of this
if we want to address this and maybe
maybe the way to ask this is what would
be is is their particular is it is the
refrigerant what what aspect should we
target first especially on the climate
side if we want to make this more
efficient and still get the benefits but
maybe reduce some of those environmental
costs well I mean so as I say this UN
sustainable cooling for all panel got
started last September and they have the
kigali agreement on reducing the
refrigerant use and obviously we've all
signed up for our Paris Accord targets
except those of us who haven't and we're
in California yeah so there are at that
level there are mechanisms in place and
I think everyone will say who looked at
the CFC success that those mechanisms
would not have worked without a lot of
investment and a lot of enforcement and
whether the investment in the
enforcement or there is a whole other
question because I am NOT a policy
person the thing that I think is people
need to care about refrigeration before
we do anything about refrigeration
people had the hole in the ozone layer
was the thing I was a kid at the time
but you could care about it because it
was it was very visceral and my my
thought you know I said I want to
reintroduce you to your refrigerator I
feel like it is an invisible system at
the moment and I would like to make it
visible and that is part of the work of
doing something about it too and and the
fact that you have a region here full of
foodies and talking about farm-to-table
and they have completely alighted this
middle step
that's ridiculous these people care
about farm-to-table and they don't care
about refrigeration they should so
that's that's at least my part of it
I've got another question I think yeah
hi I know you're not the apologist for
this lipid base coating but
right I was like first of all can I put
this on my skin I would like to bathe in
this stuff and then second of all can I
buy into it I mean so I I am the
apologist for it I'm just trying not to
be in a model of journalistic restraint
oh it's edible because it's made from
the lipids inside the the avocado seed
doesn't yeah I know you two can buy
shares no it's not a it's not a publicly
traded company I have not made but no I
I mean I I think it's um I think it's
exciting and also one thing I did think
that the guy had done that was really
smart was actually study the avocado
chain from start to finish down to sort
of assembling a replica of the avocado
packing houses to figure out and and you
know replicas about avocado packaging
and all sorts of things to understand
exactly how his system good fit and so I
just I I gave it initially I was like
you know you're a journalist you get a
press release about this you're like the
another stupid thing but just what whole
journalists think I think every person
so more or less but I when I visited I
was pretty excited yeah another question
yeah I was wondering if you it looked
like you did some research into these
kind of interstitial cooling spaces it
doesn't seem like everything needs to be
frozen or even down to 35 degrees
there's the idea of the root cellar yeah
and I've been in places where you know
in colder climates you can actually dig
into the ground and you have frozen
cellars but it seems like there's a lot
of room for these things and eggs that
actually don't need to be refrigerated
if you don't wash them the right that
Americans like to ask them so it seems
like there's a lot of room for relieving
the refrigeration stress on the world
some of these things that don't need to
be quite as cold as other things oh yeah
and there's some public service sort of
journalism to be done to around the way
that what people put in their fridges
there's sort of disillusion now I think
such you know sort of again it's that
cold storage banquet has succeeded ten
times over and now people think the
fridge is the safest place to put
everything like everything like goldfish
crackers and and and it just it you
don't need two fridges you really don't
unless you're protecting against ants I
just wanted there's one of the friends
yep here we go I'm just curious I feel
like you talked mostly about like when
you imagine the lipid coating or some of
these other things or even just like
we're talking about individual
refrigerators but I'm curious thinking
about like you know there's obviously
been a lot of coverage of like banana
like the whole process the bananas have
to go through to precisely preserve and
then ripen and all and there's other
examples of produce and things that have
to be in on mass like stored and then
set to a certain position before being
put in the store so how if we were to
say like change refrigeration at that if
you go back a step from the individual
fridge to like sort of like the mass
cargo shipping container scale weapons
well so I mean take bananas if you the
reason but not that so bananas are an
amazingly refrigerated fruit which is
weird because you don't put bananas in
your fridge at home but they have to be
transported under refrigeration and
until they could be bananas were
extremely rare so rare that you know
Scientific American published
instructions on how to peel a banana
and you know there was there's there was
a lot of when the refrigeration started
and bananas started becoming common
people did trip on banana peels and have
to be warned not to throw their bananas
on the ground and cities did pass
ordinances against it I mean all of this
banana panic was real so but it it only
works because of refrigeration and then
because when you bring you harvest the
bananas unripe which is how you're able
to transport them for so long and then
you ripen them using of a plant hormone
called ethylene and then you get them to
the store where we don't refrigerate
them but the only reason you need
refrigeration is because you're
transporting them unripe if you could
transport them ripe without them turning
into mush then you wouldn't need the
ripening rims so if the lipid coating
not to sound like an apologist for the
lipid coating but there is there is
there but if ace a way was found to
transport the referent of the bananas
and give them that extended shelf-life
so that you could harvest them when they
were ripe then you wouldn't need any of
the rest of the infrastructure you would
still need the shipping but it wouldn't
be refrigerated shipping so I mean if
you're gonna eat bananas big although I
like to think refrigeration is at the
center of the food system there is and
it is there there are some things you
know if you're gonna eat things that are
tropical they are gonna be shipped there
are still some elements of the food
system that are gonna need to be fixed
after we fix refrigeration but at least
they wouldn't be being shipped under
refrigeration and another thing that
that that brings to mind and it's we had
another talk a few months back by Susan
Atari who's is a environmental scientist
who looks at the psychology also of
consumers and one of the things she
finds is that that we don't understand
the cost of various using various
utilities and in a way we also don't
understand this for food especially by
way of how it interacts with this
artificial cryosphere mean
that if you've got something that is out
of season for instance you are you are
costing the environment more no matter
what you are paying for it to do that
but maybe this is interesting a good way
to segue into talking about some of your
other work so let's talk a little bit
about gastropod because gastropod it
seems like is is the podcast that you
you don't tell us a little bit about
this because if you you are doing this
job a little bit of informing your
audience about the realities of some of
the food the back stories and the
science behind some of the food tell us
about it and tell us maybe how you see
it's sort of fitting into you know the
the the same reason why you do you were
at this book well so gastropod is a
podcast that i co-host with cynthia
Graber and that i started because we met
on a food and farming fellowship at UC
berkeley thanks to the glorious Malia in
the front row here see we have heard to
thanks for the existence of this podcast
but it basically is the same impetus as
the book just there's so much we don't
understand about our food let's go down
a rabbit hole but with gastropod we do
it with a with a single topic each week
so the episode that we are putting out
this coming Tuesday that we're wrapping
right now so it's in my mind is well why
do we eat the animals we do this simple
question that you think how can that
sustain a podcast but it an entire
episode of a podcast but it turns out
all of our theories like oh well it must
be because these are the ones we were
able to domesticate well why were these
are the ones we were able to domesticate
it turns out these none of these reasons
quite add up and and there's a lot of
sort of yeah basically it's the same
thing as refrigeration you just kind of
keep digging until all the weird
unexpected stuff comes out and that's
what I do as a writer and I guess that's
what I do as a podcaster too and we just
did one on an episode on mangoes and
and they this little question was what
why why are indian mangoes so delicious
and american mangoes so disgusting and
disappointing not disgusting
disappointing I'll be fair and and so
that turns out to involve you know a
whole series of things and
harley-davidsons and george w bush and
the fact that Americans like red shiny
things and just it it there's a whole
sort of story built into it that you
then make an episode and this episode
drops on oh the mango one you can know
the mango ones already also walk out of
here you can hit subscribe alright
alright on your phone or you can hang
out a little bit longer and ask Mickey
some questions here right here well so I
think this project and gastropod as well
you're doing this kind of Anthropocene
journalism really at this point I mean
it feels like me does it does it feel
like there's a different I'm a different
kind of perspective it feels like that's
that's a that's a constant through here
is is that it's it's there's there's an
awareness of it's not just the thing in
front of us but it's a larger system and
and it's a history that's sort of what
at this point I think that's always what
it is with me is oh it's a larger system
and it's a story you didn't know about
how we got here and then maybe doesn't
necessarily make actually that much
sense once you know it and then once you
know that well it could be different and
that moment where you're like well it
could be different is the most exciting
moment then you let other people go away
and figure out how to make it different
people who have skills in that
department but I like the part where you
realize though because there is no real
good reason for how we or there are
series of sort of slightly random
reasons for how we got to what we have
it means we could easily blow it all up
and have a better system or a different
system alright great well I think we're
gonna have to leave it there let's have
another big round of applause
Vicky
I'd like to present you at the the long
now challenge coin to thank you for for
speaking for us remind you to seize the
millennium and all of you to seize the
millennium and it sees another drink and
stick around please and and talk more
with Nicky she's gonna be sitting around
thanks once again for coming out and
really appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]